hello good afternoon to MPs have
cancelled all public engagements after
taking part in a central London
conference where one attendee was
diagnosed with the coronavirus illness
Coe bid 19 Labour MPs Alex Sobel and
liliane Greenwood were part of the UK
Bus summit at Westminster's qe2 centre
last week along with more than 200
others well let's speak to Labour MP
Alex Sobel now hello to you Alex
and so just tell us you were at the
conference eight days ago is it now and
and when did you learn that there may be
a potential risk to you this morning
when a journalist tweeted it out and
then rang our office so I only found out
through the media rather than through
the event and I think that's because I
wasn't registered directly when I was at
a side event on a bus outside the
conference and so my name wasn't on the
list of attendees so you were on a bus
outside the conference but you have now
been in touch with public health England
and what if they told you I think that
they gave you advice that should take
reasonable precautions and so we thought
about what those would be
and because I'm an MP so right now it
should be at Sur jurisdictions we
thought that the reason precaution would
be to self isolate so I'm taking
regional messes to isolate myself until
next Wednesday evening and what do those
measures entail Alex well I'm not in
contact with anybody new I'm just a
moment I'm still at the office they also
blew up this morning and I mean at the
end meeting room in the office away from
everybody else and that I'll once I've
finished all these media reviews I'll be
going home and then I'll be isolating
myself in my home of this and I won't be
intending to leave the house until next
Wednesday right okay and and that's
because the 14 day period of advise
self-isolation has already actually
begun yes into that here already yeah
so you're sort of isolating yourself in
your office you're gonna do it at home
if you've got any plans for how you're
going to keep yourself occupied and
entertained until next Wednesday shut up
at home I suppose the weather at least
means you won't be missing out on being
outdoors um well I mean exact I don't
god I've actually you know God pile of
things to like most of these have got to
do things to read things to write
Netflix to watch so yeah I'm sure I'll
be fine I might get a little bit
stir-crazy but that's obviously much
more important that I isolate myself in
case I'm a risk than you know being a
bit bored or being a little bit
stir-crazy is a minor inconvenience and
for anyone else who was attending the
conference first they may have had some
contact with this coronavirus case just
remind us what it is the advice that
you've been given and the advice that
people should be following I think the
advice that we've been given ease as
long as you feel well then that you you
can carry on as normal I think because
myself and million other enemies of
public figures who come to contact with
a lot of people and obviously and it's
been out in the media that we took this
additional precaution so I'm not showing
any symptoms
I'm thigh I've got no fever I've got a
flu-like symptoms I've got the
respiratory issues and but as as the
evidence has shown that you can present
up to 14 days I've taken these these
measures what I really hope is really at
the early stage this in the UK is the
government do properly put the resource
into public health properly put
resources into tracking people so if
somebody does does presenting the case
that everybody gets information very
quickly in the best possible way which
you know hasn't quite happened in this
case because I found out through the
media but do you think there needs to be
a stepping up of a resource and support
for this because it has got potential
obviously become a pandemic so the
government really needs to have an
absolute and and utter focus on this
because
of public concerns okay Alex opal thanks
very much indeed for talking to us